a federal judge is threatening to hold
Attorney General Jeff Sessions and other
officials in contempt but so far there's
been no reaction from the Justice
Department judge Emmett Sullivan said it
was unacceptable for the government to
deport a mother and daughter during a
court hearing on their request for
asylum he ordered their plane to return
to the United States immediately
Matea very al is outside the detention
center in Dili Texas where the two have
now returned Madea good morning
well good morning we are being kept
across the street from a very busy
highway and about a quarter mile from
that Dilli detention facility it is the
largest in the US for families and it
houses mothers and children now the
attorneys that are representing this
mother this particular case actually say
she was fleeing gang death threats and
also an abusive husband the South Texas
family residential center in Dili Texas
seen here in video shot by US
Immigration and Customs Enforcement has
been home for Carmen and her little girl
for weeks
the mother was here while fighting the
denial of her asylum request she's part
of a lawsuit filed by the ACLU
challenging what they say are the Trump
administration's more restrictive Asylum
policies she fled to this country
seeking safety but instead she was
denied a chance to apply for asylum and
she was denied a fair hearing for her
claims the court believed the government
had agreed to keep them in the US until
midnight Thursday as a judge held an
emergency hearing instead during the
proceeding the judge learned US
officials had put the pair on a flight
back to El Salvador my heart sank
immediately in a written order the judge
scolded Attorney General Jeff Sessions
and demanded Carmen and her daughter be
sent back to the United States sources
confirmed the mother and daughter never
got off the plane in El Salvador and
headed back to the facility in Dili
Texas Thursday CBS News was given a
first-hand look at the detention center
which holds roughly 1500 mothers and
children about 10 percent of them were
once separated but have been reunited I
think the reason this place was set up
is so that we could actually preview
those people through the asylum cross
and get a final decision on what their
case is like still legal advocates
working with these families say the
criteria for deciding who stays and who
gets deported is vague we are fighting
for them to all have their fair day in
court
now that Carmen and her daughter are
coming back to this facility here in
Dili Texas a judge is expected to speed
up their case we did reach out to the
Department of Justice but we have yet to
hear back from them
Gail all right Maria thank you